groupe union pour un mouvement populaire
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
madame delphine batho ministre de
l'écologie du développement durable et
de l'énergie
elle n'est pas là et je le regrette
madame la ministre
l'indre fait partie des sites dix
départements du centre sinistré au plan
ferroviaire dans ce domaine le polt
paris orléans limoges toulouse constitue
notre seul moyen actuel n'est sa
fiabilité sa vitesse et son confort
ressemble à celle et celui des années 60
il est aussi notre seule raison
d'espérer bénéficier d'une liaison
confortable et rapide entre paris et
toulouse et ainsi être connecté au
réseau lgb national et européen
sa rénovation et sa connexion à la
future lgv peuple paris orléans clermont
lyon sont pour nous essentiel l'exigence
légitime de la haute-vienne d'atteinte
paris en deux heures sera ainsi
respectée et nous pourrons du lot au sud
au cher au nord proposé à nos habitants
à deux reprises des temps de parcours et
un confort digne de notre époque
malheureusement une partie des élus de
la haute vienne ont imaginé avec les
élus de la vienne un échappatoire vers
poitiers est de ceux là est né le projet
lgv monovoie monovoie limoges poitiers
avec en échange la participation du
limousin au financement du segment lgv
manquant entre poitiers et bordeaux
ce projet est tellement fragile en terme
de prévisions d'activité que vous avez
imaginé fausser le débat public en
asséchant habitera arbitrairement le
polt pour rendre plus crédible limoges
poitiers le courrier émanant du
ministère de l'écologie du développement
durable et de l'énergie mendiants
l'accord des élus financeurs pour cette
manoeuvre de détournement et cynique
injuste et totalement déplacé ces
procédés sont contraires aux règles de
la république ou et l'exigence
d'aménagement équitable du territoire
où est le respect de l'intérêt public où
est le respect de l'environnement
où est le respect de la bonne
utilisation de l'argent public
dans l'arborescence et je vais nationale
le limoges poitiers monovoie est une
brindille
mais cette brindille coûte entre 1
milliard et demi et 3 milliards d'euros
au moment de sa hausse à 2 sa
réalisation dans le cadre des
contraintes budgétaires et du respect de
l'environnement qui sont les nôtres
la rénovation du pote et sa connexion au
poc satisfont parfaitement aux
directives environnementales
ce qui n'est pas du tout le cas du
projet de détournement par poitiers
moins coûteux plus équitable
techniquement et commercialement plus
productifs
voilà les critères qui doit être la
priorité des élus de gouvernement les
départements concernés attendent le
maintien d'un axe une matière d'un axe
polt rénové est connecté au peuple ce
qui impliquera le non détournement de sa
clientèle géographiquement naturel nous
comptons sur vous ainsi que sur le
gouvernement
merci monsieur alain vidalis ministre
chargé des relations avec le parlement
merci à monsieur le président monsieur
sénateurs voudraient bien excuser
l'absence de madame bateau qui
accompagne le premier ministre dans un
voyage officiel au au canada vous
évoquez ici d'une part deux projets de
lgv la lgv poitiers limoges et la lgv
paris orléans clermont ferrand lyon dit
polk et d'autre part la ligne actuelle
paris orléans limoges toulouse dit polt
l'ensemble ces questions fait l'objet
d'une attention particulière du
gouvernement étant donné leur importance
en terme d'aménagement et de
développement de nos territoires
le projet de lgv poitiers limoges est
actuellement en phase préalable à
lenquête public
il s'agit d'une étape importante qui
nécessite que les collectivités
territoriales cofinanceurs soient
étroitement associés à l'élaboration du
dossier qui sera présentée au public
c'est la raison pour laquelle les
hypothèses concernant les différentes
possibilités de desserte tenant compte
des nouveaux services permis par la lgv
ont fait l'objet des changes entre
l'état rff et les collectivités
territoriales
l' enquête publique est une phase des
changes démocratique visant à recueillir
les expressions de l'ensemble des
acteurs à l'issue de laquelle le projet
peut être amené à évoluer les hypothèses
de desserte présentés dans le dossier d'
enquête sur l'avenir des dessertes de la
ligne polt sont une base de travail
permettant d'éclairer le débat à venir
elle ne préjuge pas des circulations sur
cette ligne qui relève de la convention
conclue entre l'état et la sncf portant
sur l'exploitation de l'ensemble des
trains d'équilibré du territoire
la lgv polk vient quant à elle de faire
l'objet d'un débat public achevée depuis
2012 et une nouvelle phase d'étude vient
d'être engagé il s'agira de définir les
conditions de la faisabilité financière
du projet d'approfondir son évaluation
socio-économique et de préciser les
performances des dessertes envisageable
la commission mobilité 21 est chargé
d'examiner les différents projets
d'infrastructures de transport dont ses
deux lgv et de proposer les orientations
pour une politique de transport
soutenable les conclusions de cette
commission sont attendues d'ici la fin
du mois de juin
à notre sens des lgv la l'inexistence
doivent pas être considérés comme des
infrastructures en concurrence mais
complémentaires il n'est en effet pas
question d'opposer les infrastructures
qui n'assure pas les mêmes services la
ligne polt devra ainsi continuer à
assurer une desserte fine des
territoires situés sur cet axe nord-sud
est essentielle à l'aménagement de notre
pays
ces différentes démarches sont engagées
dans une approche responsable et sont
nécessaires en préalable pour permettent
d'éclairer les décisions à prendre pour
l'avenir de notre réseau ferroviaire et
l'aménagement de nos territoires